there's no time
13 o clock
[Music]
hey y'all it's us again and it's episode
173 yeah this is a legendary story here
going back to the paranormal on this one
somebody actually requested this and I
was shocked shocked I tell you that we
had never done a show on this because
this legend of the Bell Witch yeah I
actually grew up hearing this a lot
because both of my paternal grandparents
were from Springfield Tennessee which is
very near the current town of Adams
where all of the chicanery took place
yeah this is some real you know almost
pre rednecks yeah rednecks spoke with a
British accent Victorian okay man he's
certain earlier all right [ __ ] offer but
yeah so it's like so growing up it's
like you know my grandparents had the
you know what they now called the red
book the authenticated history of the
Bell which which was written by Martin
Ingram and they also had and I'm really
mad because I can't find it I used to
have like a really small like pamphlet
size book that was um I think it was
echoes at the Bell which in the 20th
century was I think what it was called
and I have it in here somewhere but I
couldn't find the [ __ ] because I was
looking for it for the show like before
we started recording and I'm like where
the [ __ ] is that and I've been like to
tear in my bookshelves apart in [ __ ]
like that
and I can't find it but I do have it
somewhere I promise but so yeah this was
something that you know my grandparents
heard when they were growing up and they
kind of like passed it down to us I feel
like the legend the legend wasn't really
all that well known I feel like until
probably the Blair Witch Project came
out in 1999 which is not directly based
on the Bell Witch legend but it kind of
like took aspects of it and
fictionalized it because after that came
out like four or five movies based on
the Bell Witch haunting came out most of
which are terrible in the very early 80s
after I had
my experience with Mammoth Mountain
poultrygeist as a teenager I went
through all the paranormal and ghost
books I could find and this is one of
the ones that came up and I read it and
I was like boy that sure does sound like
a poltergeist case yes similar to mine
but not quite as detailed you know I
mean an inner woven with a lot of
different people I just kind of took the
story at face value but back in the
early 80s the Bell which must have been
a local phenomenon nobody else in doing
it was yeah all right because I would
mention it every now and then and nobody
would know what it was and you never
heard it mentioned it was only in the
modern era yeah like I said because I
mean I grew up hearing it because my
grandparents were from there and the
modern era really you could from for me
the modern eras the last 20 years yeah I
heard about it a little bit around that
Blair Witch time yeah their Witch
Project time Blair Witch Project was
really inspired by this poltergeist yeah
like I said it's not exactly the same
but they did use aspects of the legend
like in the Blair Witch I think the
stories are kind of different though I
don't I didn't really see Blair Witch I
just saw a little bits and pieces yeah
but I kind of think well we'll get into
this later
I kind of think that genre is very
similar I think it might be the same
genre yeah I kind of have that suspicion
what a dramatic statement we just made
yeah but there's a lot more there's a
lot to the case historically and also in
parapsychology I think I don't think it
was made up out of whole cloth yeah it's
just that you start looking at the dates
and we're gonna get into that too yeah I
am just like so I've been like spending
the last two or three days I've watched
like every single documentary I watched
a bunch of the movies that were based on
it even the loosely based ones you know
I've read a bunch of different people's
websites and stuff I think the problem
with the belt but I mean the reason that
I find it an interesting story and that
I always found an interesting story
growing up is because I find this type
of folklore very fascinating like and I
even if it didn't really happen the way
that it was supposed to have happened
which I suspect that it did not I'm
gonna tell you it didn't happen the way
they said it yeah some of this may have
happened we're gonna see you know yeah
now whether or not all this stuff
happened in the same case I don't know
right but I'm getting ahead of myself
shoutouts yeah we should do the
shoutouts first and then what I was
gonna do like cuz cuz like I said I've
got like three different like files of
notes on this that I'm just gonna kind
of go back and forth hopefully without
messing them up what I was gonna do is I
was kind of going to we'll go into like
the legend like what the legend is what
it says what it says like what was
supposed to happen from and all this
other kind of stuff I also wanted to get
a little bit into some later on
published accounts of people that said
that they had had encounters with the
entity like later on made in the 20th
century and stuff and then after that I
kind of want to get into maybe some
debunking type of stuff maybe some
historical inaccuracy inaccuracies and
other kind of like interesting things
about what really happened around that
time period around the people that were
in supposedly involved in it that you
know maybe suggest something else was
going on you know I'm saying look it
could be the Blair Witch Blair wish
could be that the Bell which case you
know is your favorite case and you
believe that everything in this case
we're not here to [ __ ] on this case I'm
not gonna [ __ ] on this case I find this
very interesting ever since I was a kid
case but we might have a slightly
different take on this case yeah yeah I
mean we have to I haven't
having witnessed poltergeist myself I
have a different interpretation of what
I'm what I'm seeing here
yeah and we're negating there yeah we'll
get into that and like I said other
other people other writers have kind of
come at it from how you're coming to
have this yeah like I said I tried to
read like all different kind of bogus
sources about this and I just know the
legends I really haven't it's not my job
to read it what other people say about
the legend right you know what I mean
because I want to keep my opinion pool
untainted I want to be have an original
opinion even if it even if it lines up
with what somebody else thinks at least
I came to that conclusion and on your
own right
I get that I get that all right so
before we get into talking about the
legend of the Bell which we have a
couple of shout outs firstly I would
like to thank Melanie for her very
generous PayPal donation Christmas
present she said so thank you very much
Melanie she she often sends us very
generous donations and they are all very
much appreciated I would also like to
thank hey soos who also sent us a PayPal
donation this week also very much
appreciated you might as well use we got
and it's Christmas time jesus loves our
show that's how I think of it from money
heavy money David Bowie mentions that on
in the Tim machine that's right yeah
money comes from money heaven and you
know different types of food come from
different type of food if like there's a
Twinkie heaven there's happen for
everything I think he has this yes all
right thank you very much also I
mentioned this on patreon but are $20
and up patrons we are putting together
the shirt that we're gonna send out to
you guys I love this [ __ ] shirt well
I like how it came out I told him what
the shirt is no I only just finished
designing it it's [ __ ] awesome okay
it's a 13 o'clock and here's this is
this is relevant to this month this
month there will be a Friday the 13th
there will be yes okay so the shirt will
be a Friday the 13th movie mashup with
13 o'clock so it says 13 o'clock but
it's coming at you like the Friday motif
from from the very first movie the first
breaking through the glass yeah
it kind of it doesn't look exactly the
same but it like suggests that suggest
that we couldn't do it because it's got
to be in one color and to get the
shading right we had to do some stuff
too yeah but it looks enough like it
that it you'll know what it is I mean I
you know I know what it is and I found
like the other the font that you had
like I think the second and third one
like somebody designed a font called
Friday 13 that's free yeah that's just
like the font on the posters and like I
saw whoever you are
but it's a different than the same angle
in it yeah yeah it's got different
shading on it yeah well the the big
glass people 13 because what I did was I
did kind of a mash-up of two different
posters because like I said there's one
that had the 13th like Friday 13th like
coming at you like coming out of like
glass and that's just like a plain font
that's just I think it was just
Helvetica yeah but the other font that
was on some of the later posters and
some of the alternate first movie
posters is kind of like a rough look and
you know what I mean almost like a
handwriting font and so I have like a
little like the subtext in that one you
know what I mean so if so I sent like
all the $20 patrons a message on patreon
you know making sure that I have your
most current mailing address make sure
you know do you want to mnsure to
women's shirt you know what size you
want stuff like that so I've got several
of you have gotten back to me but if you
haven't gotten back to me please try to
do that by like around the 15th or like
the middle of the month this should be a
salary I think if anybody wants to buy
this shirt just without being a
subscriber just leave us a message in
the you know in the comments and we'll
we'll get with you well make extra yeah
because we just basically just make as
many like we make them for the patrons
there's somebody by somewhere I'll make
more yeah and then like I said we might
I don't know I might put some up on
either hand made by us this is not gonna
be yeah we screen print them yeah this
was gonna be screening for ourselves
right so so yeah so if your body's gonna
be if you're a twenty dollar nut patron
you know you should check your email cuz
I did send you a message about that um
other than that just the regular
shoutouts go check out my book The
Associated villanies which like I said
it's short stories horror stories have
it I did like a second edition new print
version new eBook version and I also did
a audiobook version which is the first
time that I've ever done that so go
check that out and also faceless villain
3 obviously is also available in all
three formats I probably like I said I'm
gonna do on my fiction and eventually I
think enough people have recommended
that I do a fourth faceless volume
called like millennium or something like
that that's you know 2000 to 2019 just
because I mean it's there
there and like it's 20 years just like
the other ones were and you know it just
we're just now ending so I figured well
that's probably the next thing or that
will probably not be out until probably
late next year I would imagine yeah but
I might start working on that like an
immediate cook up something kind of like
a four book package deal to buy the
whole series yeah I'm gonna try and see
if I can figure out how I can do that
I mean Amazon will usually do that on
purpose because you know they have that
thing where it's like if you buy one
thing like underneath it says you know
if you buy like these two things
together then you get like five bucks
off or some [ __ ] like that they do that
sometimes for they don't have it so you
can have you can sell them in a package
like with new packaging around all four
I don't think so I would have to I mean
I could look into it because like I said
I do you know I sell through Amazon
through what used to be create space but
it's not called that anymore
but I don't think I could do that but I
would have to do that as like a special
edition type of thing and then I would
have to like design the box separate it
would yeah probably because that would
be like a lot of extra I'm right
b-better John five series yeah I mean I
I have thought about maybe in the future
doing like a big like a hardback with
all of the books in one volume like with
like a timeline and all that other kind
of stuff but that you know I might do
that eventually just because I enjoy it
in paperback ah yeah it would be yet
because it would be well over a thousand
babies I mean I think I put the three
books together like in one file like an
InDesign or something like that and I
think it end up being like 1200 pages or
some [ __ ] and it's like you know there's
only so I think the paperback books I
think you can only go up to 800 pages or
900 pages okay like because they s the
way they print it in the spine and
whatever they don't really let you do
that but you know we'll see how that
goes
we'll just I'll figure it out I just
dish if whatever liking by the seat of
my pants I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing
yeah you do well you know we talked
about it in advance but well sometimes
it can try some stuff and we run into
problems then we had to fix it and some
some things never really happened yeah
we planted it never really happened well
yeah for whatever reason that public
doesn't really know
bottom yeah so but that everything we
bring to market recently the quality's
been really good this is because the new
recording equipment yeah we've
definitely probably what the problem is
our early audio books we gotta go and
they're almost all of them replaced I
think yeah except for the really short
ones I've redone all of the audio on my
mountain was is it good enough does it
need to be replaced um I might
eventually redo that but we were talking
about expanding that you look out we
might do that and if you yeah they're
like making it longer we can expand I
can improve on that story yeah
with more details and the Steve
marijuana's I might eventually end up
putting those two short books together
in a longer volume with another case of
his see when we first came up with
mammoth mountain poltergeist I wanted it
to be a short and clinical as possible
yeah because I wanted people in the
parapsychology you know a racket field I
thought yeah it seems like a loaded I'm
not sure I'm not sure pair psychologists
are what they used to be less than the
ones some of the [ __ ] that I've heard
him say but I wanted I wanted it to be
kind of short and concise for them and
to be kind of clinical and so people
thought that it was even scarier that it
was like that yeah well that's kind of
what I was shooting for yeah cuz I found
it a very scary story yeah to me it's
like it's scarier if you don't embellish
it that's why I don't really find like I
like some paranormal shows like a
haunting and stuff but I don't find them
particularly scary because they like the
thing is though as they allege reminded
me of a couple more stories and things
that had happened later on didn't they
yeah where was that in there too about
the Matchbox cars yeah that wasn't that
was in there okay I mean you know we
could like I'm gonna reread it again
yeah and then you can like think if
there was other stuff so that's like
another project that we were thinking
about doing yeah that may or may not
come some of the stuff involving Wesley
came out of Wesley's mouth and I'm not
sure he knew it knew what I was asking
him to I don't know yeah we might have
to like Rican ductus he kind of changes
his story you know every time I ask him
him being kind cuz I missed it yeah I
mean he knew something was going army he
didn't really know what it was right and
I mean at this point I mean bread has
passed away
Louis and Wesley are still alive yeah
but uh we might maybe we can reenter
view them or yeah well stuff happened
after that though - that's true that
maybe should go in there yeah that's
true
so yeah that's another thing that we
might do next year sometime all right so
are you ready to talk about yeah the
legend of the Bell Witch yeah all right
so this story supposedly began in the
early 19th century now there was a
family the Bell family obviously the
patriarch of which was John Bell now
over the winter of 1804 to 1806 in
County Tennessee now this was a
community and at the time it was called
Red River later on the name was changed
to Adams station and nowadays it's just
called Adams but at the time it was
called Red River so he moved there he
bought you know several acres of land I
believe it was over 300 acres and built
a large house there for his family now
him and his wife Lucy eventually ended
up having I think they had seven kids
altogether three of them were born in
Tennessee like after they'd moved there
the other four had been born while they
were still in North Carolina now the
trouble began allegedly in 1817 now
pretty much every you know every version
of the legend that I've read the first
thing that happened was that John Bell
was either out hunting or he was out
like [ __ ] around in his cornfield you
know looking at the ears or whatever and
he sees like a weird-looking animal
sitting in the middle of one of the corn
rows this animal reportedly had a dog's
body and a rabbit's head yeah now
supposedly John Bell was very um
discombobulated let's say by the
appearance of this bizarre-looking
Anthony what when I first found this
when I first found this case was reading
reading about it a few years
after the whole mountain thing went down
and he gave that description I was just
wondering if a poltergeist could do that
it did kind of freak me out
it's weird because I wrote about some
other cases maybe this was a thing like
maybe this was like a trope yeah because
I wrote about some other cases like in
the unseen hand where people supposedly
saw like unusual animals I mean look at
that there was that whole Jeff - talking
Mongoose thing yeah there was and I've
seen like a couple of other cases where
people reported seeing a funny-looking
animal yeah you see I think I had
already read those other cases by the
time I you know what I mean we've got to
this one Oh cuz this one was less rare
than the talking Mongoose one actually
yeah
this one was more rare more rather than
talking walking mind that one I think
was way more well-known oh and I was
like my poltergeist never showed me any
animals or any strange animals and I
thought at the time it was either some
kind of a just a fabrication or maybe
they were having hallucinations that
maybe a good older guy should make you
think you saw something
yeah like inserted a damn psychic image
in your head but then later on as I
started to read more and more started
getting into demonology and some of the
accounts of demonology that go back to
like the 14 to 1500s describes strange
like satanic animals it's very common
like I said it's a very common thing in
these types that I have a feeling that
this was that the mixed strange animal
thing was something out of witchcraft in
demonology
book I can't suspect that so that's what
that's what they're reporting and that's
supposed to be supposed to harken back
to like what was it the malum affectaura
was the name of that [ __ ] book about
malleus Maleficarum malleus Maleficarum
er of the witches yeah because I think
that I think that type of imagery is in
that so I think it is yeah now that I'm
thinking I have a copy of it somewhere
but I don't know where that is on a
person with it with a Christian
upbringing would have mentioned that I
like how a person with an Islamic
background will always mention jinns
yeah they see anything
paranormal I feel like the thing about
the weird animals is maybe it's kind of
like shorthand for an unholy creature
and it's like a harbinger of a bad [ __ ]
- counting demonic yeah yeah I feel like
that's probably what it is because I I
do see it that type of that trope like
turns up in a lot of these types of
stories and it's usually usually a lot
of them are from like the 16th or 17th
century and I feel like it's always kind
of like oh it's demonic and like it
signifying something it fell out of
popularity but I think you could say
that that reappeared a little bit in
Hollywood with the omen with the damn
dog yeah although black dogs that's like
that's like a big thing and I made
particularly in England - I mean there's
like even now to this day as far as I
know there's still like a sightings of
black dogs and things like that and it's
always like you know it's supposed to be
like a like an ill omen you know well
that's what this is so that might be
what this is but very specifically this
was supposed to look like a dog body
with a rabbit head right so now John
Bell shot at it apparently but then it
disappeared now reportedly Bell thought
this was kind of weird as you would but
he's just like oh well maybe I just
didn't see it right or maybe it was just
some weird animal or I don't know this
is like a mutant or whatever so he just
goes back to the house and didn't really
think any more about it now apparently
that night at the house the whole family
started hearing what sounded like
knocking or beating sounds like on the
outside walls of their house this is
common in old-fashioned poltergeist
reports yeah knocking yeah and this is
usually the first manifestation it's
usually starts which was strange because
I didn't know anything about poltergeist
phenomenon when I had my poltergeist
episode happened and it didn't start
with knocking yeah but I'm thinking
maybe the knocking the reports of
knocking maybe that might be related to
spiritualism later on I feel like that
might in the 1800's well yeah because it
was at 1848 the Fox sisters yeah
that were like cracking their toe doing
some whatnot like making knocking sounds
like to answer
but it's easy to replicate knocks during
séances Hellyeah area and that i think i
think that god it kind of got into the
zeitgeist that when spirits appear
you're gonna hear knocking yeah so they
can't fulfill two different things right
there didn't they mm-hmm a satanic
animal and knocking yeah so they got
their grounds covered they got the bases
covered yeah
you noticed that too yeah well like i
said there's a lot of very common troops
in this yeah story yeah and and they're
they're they're reporting two of the
most common beginnings of something
paranormal but back old-school style
yeah you know sixteen hundred [ __ ] oh
yes definitely an eighteen hundreds it's
either knocking or like rocks falling on
them yeah that's like that's one of the
two most common right beginnings of like
paranormal activity yeah okay so yeah so
they start hearing these noises on the
outside of their house there were also
some other kind of unusual things
reported around this time one of the
bells sons whose name was Drew or Drury
I guess it was Drury Andrew was short
for it
speaking of weird animals he supposedly
saw a bird whose species he could not
ascertain that was a like kind of
sitting on a fence and he said it was
like really really big and he had never
seen a bird like that before and he like
shot and it flew away the youngest
daughter Betsy who would become the
target of the manifestations later on
she also said that she saw a girl in a
green dress swinging from the limb of an
oak tree one of these slaves of the
family whose name was Dean which was
actually short for APRA Dean he actually
said that he would go to visit his wife
at night you know like going home from
the Bell house and he would be followed
by a mysterious black dog all the time
so the sounds keep getting worse and
worse you know the you know the knocking
and beating on the walls and stuff they
start hearing it pretty much every night
you know
John Bell and the sons would like run
outside to see who it was or something
was out there and of course nothing was
ever there then it kind of progressed on
to a point where
apparently the bill the bell children
were waking up in the middle of the
night and they said that there they
heard like animals gnawing like on their
bed posts or they heard like scratching
or gnawing types of sound they read and
they thought it was rats like um you
know chewing on their bed it's another
commonly reported you know audio
phenomenon for the beginning of
poltergeist
yeah scratching scratching in the inside
of the walls and or chewing yeah it's
you know less common like it's rats but
then they can't find you but then they
can't find any rats and that was
apparently the case in this situation
then a little bit further along the kids
started reporting that their covers were
being pulled off them in the middle of
the night also very common their pillows
would be thrown off onto the floor they
also reported that there were sounds of
dogs fighting in the room but you
couldn't see any dogs
they also said there were sounds like
that sounded like chains being dragged
across the floor that's real old school
yeah that's like a Christmas carol that
first time that one was reported was in
range in Rome what the chains being
dragged across the floor
yeah who was it what's this rope I don't
know somebody turned around so I saw
damn ghosts with chains rattling his
chains and then he refused to see that
he said he was a man of logic and not
superstitious that wasn't there I didn't
it was the way like I said it was like a
Christmas carol he was a fragment of an
underdone potato and when he looked back
it wasn't there yeah he said ghosts
didn't exist yeah okay it's all one but
it wasn't real well he prepped well I
mean because the logical assumption you
would make is that well I must be seeing
[ __ ] yeah I mean because that's that's
like less of a leap then ghosts exude
abandon he saw a ghost and then he was
scared and [ __ ] listen he denied it he
said he saw the damn ghost yeah he saw
the ghost but he didn't believe in
ghosts they don't exist so he looked
away therefore so therefore he wasn't
there and there's but he looked back and
it was gone
okay God that [ __ ] saw the ghost so you
know
now also reportedly around this time and
I I don't think I attribute this to
anything paranormal but John Bell began
experiencing paralysis like around his
mouth and stuff now the reason I say
that I don't tribute that to anything
paranormal is that because according to
several sources John Bell suffered from
some undisclosed malady but I've seen
some sources say that it was likely
Bell's palsy which is actually not named
after him it was named before that
before him but it's kind of like a like
some nerve damage in your face or
something like that where it's kind of
like you know you you kind of like can't
move half your face and stuff like that
so he had something like that and I
think at this point it was starting to
manifest itself
now as the phenomena continued the
family then reported that they started
hearing whispering voices now at first
they couldn't understand what these
voices were saying cuz they were very
feeble and very quiet they said
sometimes it sounded like an old woman's
voice and that she was singing like
hymns or religious songs also around
this time that the voices started as I
said before the youngest daughter Betsy
started becoming the clear focus of the
attacks she would often be slapped
around like in her bedroom and they
would reportedly there would be like
hand shaped like welts like on her face
and her body and stuff like that where
this entity was supposedly slapping her
and that was reported many times since
then - yeah that's uh that's again very
common all of this stuff is very common
commonly reported and numerous numerous
poltergeist cases also pulled her hair a
lot one story I read I read said that
they took that the entity would take her
hair and like tie it like around the
bedpost so like when she woke up she
couldn't get up and stuff like that
again that's very common now apparently
at this point John Bell was like he
tells the families like look he doesn't
I guess it's like freaking them out
obviously they also seem like kind of
ashamed of it and they don't want to
tell anybody about it that's what that's
what me Louis and read notes our
reaction yeah we won't tell anybody
about
well we had the sneaking suspicion that
if you told somebody that it would stop
yeah they look like a fool and then when
they believed it would just do it again
well probably the way it was if it's
real that's probably what it would do I
mean this you know that's how it acted
yeah he wanted it to do something
sometimes it would just be like [ __ ] you
yeah he would just be like that cartoon
with the singing frog where it's like it
would sing around that one guy but then
when he brought somebody else yeah like
when you put it on stage in charge
people wouldn't we knew it's game early
on just frustrating you're all the
champs of getting down to the bottom of
it yeah yeah that makes sense
so because John Bell didn't want to tell
the world at large about his apparent
poltergeist problem but he did kind of
one another like an outside witness or
whatever so he consults with his best
friend who was also his neighbor whose
name was James Johnston and kind of told
him about it and said you know can you
come over and see if you can figure out
what's going on so James johnston
apparently comes over to the bell house
with his wife and they're gonna spend
the night over there
apparently the phenomena did manifest
itself that evening and Johnston did see
it so the next day he's like he pretty
much tells John Bell he's like well you
know I think you have a spirit like a
biblical type of spirit so I guess he
means kind of like a demonic spirit I
guess is what the implication was there
now even though I'm presumably John Pell
told his friend hey keep this on the
down-low but I guess that didn't happen
because not long after Johnston and his
wife had stayed at the house and
experienced the phenomena
word started to leak out about this
paranormal activity going on at the Bell
household there the Red River so you
know apparently so people started trying
to come to the farm like from
neighboring towns and stuff to see what
was going on also at this point it seems
that the entity if that's what it was
as I said before they just heard like
kind of whispering and singing and stuff
but eventually the the voice got louder
and more distinct and would eventually
end up like carrying on entire
conversations so
Johnston the first thing that he asked
to the spirit was who are you and what
do you want and apparently the
apparition said I am a spirit I was once
very happy but I have been disturbed
so some versions of the legend have have
them finding like a skull or some bones
or something like that on a nearby Mound
and saying that that was a person that
you know whose uncle you know unquiet
spirit it was or whatever but that's not
usually that's just in some versions of
it that I've seen you with the
implication that this is like a ghost
that lived there and wasn't at rest for
whatever reason it also gave different
once it kind of started talking it also
gave different kind of stories about its
origin like it would say something like
oh that there's there was a disturbance
to a Native American burial ground
around here which I think was where you
know that kind of trip began yeah and
evidently it's just speaking out of thin
air yeah no one um as far as I know
other than Betsy Bell reporting sink and
girl hanging from a tree and some people
subsequently that said that they saw a
figure or a shadow like in Bell Witch
cave like later on I don't think anyone
ever saw this entity it was always there
was always a voice yeah and you know
there was always paranormal like you
know poltergeist a phenomena but nobody
ever saw any that's not anything that
particular effect was in my poltergeist
experience it only spoke once and it
wasn't you couldn't comprehend what it
said it was just yeah you said it sounds
like a like some underwater like a water
yeah barrel water coolers are man rivers
are and then on this book right here
which is really I think the definitive
book on the [ __ ] case right there
that one all right long out of print
this house is haunted guy Lyon Playfair
yes poltergeist spoke a lot the Enfield
poltergeist but it spoke out of them out
of the of a girl yeah
and I kind of think it was it also make
dog noises yeah I don't think it was
paranormal in the way he would think
something was paranormal I think a
poltergeist focused sometimes can start
to manifest something similar to
Tourette's syndrome yeah that's what I
think it's voices you know voices from
the subconscious the thing that's
actually causing all this you can get
back to this goes back to young you know
yeah the was it the unconscious yeah
definitely that's what that's what I
think it is now whether or not in this
particular case was there talking we'll
get to that later yeah I I don't I don't
want to really you know we'll just let
this unfold and then you'll gotta get in
I'll get into a little bit yeah a little
bit more so like I said there were
different stories about what the what
this entity said that it was like I said
Native American burial ground and also
reportedly told drew Bell which is one
of John Bell sons and a friend of his or
a neighbor of theirs that there was a
hidden treasure like somewhere around
there and the two guys went like very
excitedly and dug out the place and then
reportedly they didn't find anything and
then the entity laughed at them for
being so dumb like falling for it one
very famous story about the Bell which
is that one time she repeated two
sermons being given thirteen miles apart
you know what I mean like she knew
exactly what the sermons were and he's
too different and it was two different
denominations I think if one was a
Baptist Church one was a Methodist
Church or something like that so the
this entity appeared to know like a lot
about the Bible like had a lot of you
know biblical text memorized and liked
arguing about different biblical matters
different religious matters also
supposedly would knew what was going on
in neighbors houses and like would kind
of share gossip with the family it's
like hey guess what these people next
door yeah
reportability yeah yeah so that's that's
another common thing and also in cases
of kind of possession and there's
overlap there's over there's an overlap
between poltergeist case and possession
you can misdiagnosed poltergeist as of
possession also and in certain cases you
know the the poltergeist focus or the
kid that's you know responsible for a
lot of this has knowledge that he
couldn't was he or she could not possess
like knowing how how much to the exact
scent how much money somebody has in
their pocket yeah that kind of weird
stuff you know where you know like where
somebody got a certain object like a
necklace that they're wearing you know I
know who gave that to you yeah and stuff
it's just a weird phenomenon and you
know Carl Jung would have a lot to say
about it yeah yeah you know cosmic
unconsciousness is and stuff like that
yeah ether yeah bility to access
information that you know would
seemingly be impossible but it's like
quantum consciousness it's quantum
information yeah it's like the part of
your consciousness that's like LinkedIn
it's linked in with everything right I
guess I could say that okay you know in
that let in that new movie that we saw
was a doctor sleep yeah when that person
goes out of body it was the color the
quantum unconscious was kind of like the
cosmic unconscious because he pictured
it as remember a filing cabinet
yeah won't do the filing cabinets yeah
to find information yeah which is how I
always kind of thought of that type of
stuff well when I had Simoes out-of-body
experiences that I was aware that you
could do that yeah I was didn't have the
time yeah which is weird because you're
in a timeless state which I that's
that's something else I covered in
another show we did hear about the
out-of-body experience yeah that was a
while back but yeah we did do a show
about that
yeah and NDE near-death experience yeah
cuz you kind of talked a lot about cuz
you've had both of those so and who else
has been talking about this in the
mainstream be Joe Rogan yeah Joe Rogan
talks about this when he's talking about
taking ayahuasca and some of these weird
drugs and I don't laugh at it yeah I
would I could easily believe that
some of these weird mind-altering drugs
might allow you to access certain forms
of consciousness that normally are only
able you would only be able to achieve
while you're in some kind of trance or
possibly even only when you were dead
could you access that that form of
consciousness yeah or dying but I'd love
to try I'm kind of curious as well
talking to alien Souls and stuff like
that and what they tell you it turns out
to be true that kind of [ __ ] so that's
what they report yeah you have to go
over to the Yucatan Peninsula to get
that [ __ ] go on some kind of spirit walk
with some Shaymin yeah I say it makes
you sick as a dog man I've heard that
yeah yeah diarrhea and everything you
know might as well just stay naked and
[ __ ] yeah so again um you know going
back to what you were saying about you
know maybe pulling knowledge out of you
know the consciousness consciousness or
whatever a couple of other stories about
the Bell which were that John Johnston
he was James's son he actually wanted to
prove I guess so the story goes that the
entity was real or wasn't just like one
of the family members like playing a
trick or whatever so he asked it
something that only someone and his
family would know evidently the question
that he asked was you know my his step
grandmother was Dutch and she lived back
in North Carolina still he's like now if
one of the slaves did something bad in
the household what would she say to them
because she had a thing that she said to
them and apparently the Bell Witch
answered correctly and answered in the
accent of the woman which they thought
was very weird also there was another
there was another story about a guy who
was unnamed but he's an Englishman and
he actually came to the Bell house
because he had heard about the legend he
was curious about it
even though he was like skeptical he
wanted to see that it was all [ __ ]
so he said that so apparently he's
trying to talk to this spirit or
whatever and the spirit like starts
talking in the voice of his parents back
in England and he said it sounded too
exactly like them and apparently the
witch then like woke him up and the
voices of his parents were saying that
they were worried about him because back
in England they had heard his voice like
coming out of thin air so that's another
kind of story about it yeah and if this
is true then this is a quite a quite a
special case because poltergeists have
been known to like I said speak through
the voice box of someone else or to use
someone else call it kind of like
they're in a trance state because
evidently Jen Hobson could do it for
hours yeah but poltergeists speaking out
of thin air it's very rarely ever
reported and if it is it's usually only
a word or two yeah you know this was I
mean apparently this was entire
conversation have an entire conversation
yes odd I almost kind of red flag that
well I do as well but like I said yeah
so now even though from the beginning of
the manifestations the Bell Witch who
like I said it's it's not a witch
obviously but they just just got that
tag kind of later on it was a real
[ __ ] to Betsy Bell and it would do
like mischievous things I mean to her it
seemed like it was like violent toward
her and stuff however the weird thing
was that John bells wife Lucy for some
reason the Bell Witch really really
liked her called her the most perfect
woman to walk the earth would sing her
songs when she was sick she would bring
her things like nuts and grapes and
stuff like that and leave them on her
bed like for her to snag whatever a
Jekyll and Hyde personality air could
hate you
yeah it was really weird but that's one
thing that's very commonly reported that
it's like really really liked the mom
for whatever reason I never done
anything to hurt her so you know as I
said the
The Voice started getting you know
louder started having conversations and
stuff and so the story goes it drew the
attention of Andrew Jackson who would
become the seventh president but was at
this time a major general in the US Army
now although now he did own apparently
he did own some property in the Red
River area although I'm not sure if he
really was in this area at the time but
the story goes that he had heard about
the Bell which and it was really curious
about it and since he owned some land
around there he thought he would just go
check it out
so apparently this was in 1819 so
Jackson and a bunch of his men like show
up on the Bell farm like in a wagon or
whatever so they approach the property
and the wagon comes to a dead stop and
they can't get it to go again the wheels
froze yes so the yeah the wheels froze
up or something of that nature so all of
the guys are getting there trying to
push it they're trying to like do
something it won't budge and so at this
point Jackson is said to have proclaimed
by the eternal boys that must be the
Bell which and then apparently a voice
that came coming out of a bush over
there said they said it sounded like
metallic that this metallic female voice
comes out of a bush and says yeah you
can go on ahead now but I'll see you
later like at the house like you know
what I mean
so Jackson and the guys like go on to
the house and then you know apparently
Andrew Jackson and John Bell start
having this big long discussion about
various other things he had some [ __ ]
body guard with and it was a badass who
had his pistol loaded Silver Bullet
that's what I was just gonna say one of
his retinue was this guy I don't know
what his name is I saw like on one
website that it was like this Colonel
Gordon or something like that he claimed
to be a which layer or a which tamer and
he said so apparently they've been
sitting around the house and like
nothing is happening he tamed him by
laying I'm like I have no idea what that
is all about so and I don't eat em
[ __ ] dad
I don't even know like how the data
submission how do you get how do you get
the reputation of being a witch tamer
I mean well yeah it was like yeah how
many witches do you encounter in the
course of your day-to-day life you could
like get that reputation that would
proceed yeah I would admit you know this
whole part of the story I think this is
this kind of a self-professed yeah which
taper yeah I think this part of the
story is like the icing on the cake it's
it's it's a part of story to add
credibility to the rest of the story the
hey man president so I yeah even though
he wasn't president at the time but
we're gonna get into that I think it was
like ten years later gonna be named
right later
the more the more you know this story
the more it seems like a Hollywood movie
yeah all right I would agree with that
and in my experience my personal
experience poultrygeist cases don't have
plots to them yeah and they don't have
very many characters and there's never
any resolution yeah and also the people
outside the sphere of the phenomenon
don't believe that it's happening yeah
it's not something that goes viral yeah
yeah there's just not enough evidence
left over from each little occurrence
well I you know the the problem with a
lot of these and I ran into this a lot
when I was writing the book about it is
that pretty much the only evidence that
you have is funny witness testimony and
its terribleness
which is generally not a very good yeah
not very good evidence in the best of
circumstances
no physical evidence other than that
little sheet of toilet paper with the
three dress of blood on it yeah which is
one of our Bloods that blood didn't just
come from nowhere we don't know how I
got it yeah I just did it and we have
some pictures of the things that it did
you know yeah they're in the book you
know just but it's stuff that a human
could do yeah since I mean it you can't
prove anything from that yeah because
they're like what you just did that
only thing that in terms of physical
evidence of that's let lends credibility
to my stories why the [ __ ] are we
pictures of this ship yes it was in 81
I'm gonna go getting at my damn time
machine and go back to 81 and take
pictures of some towels folded up towels
or towels shaped in smiley faces and
[ __ ] yeah I should note to it I think it
was punt they polaroid pictures yeah and
that wasn't cheap back then it's like
why would you why would you waste money
like taking pictures they're just like a
bed without just the things that they
did yeah yeah man move [ __ ] but that's
what we were - yeah and I'm just like
you know why would you take pictures of
that yeah and waste like I said I
remember Polaroid film being expensive
and there weren't that many pictures
winter it was really weird you know yeah
but I'll tell you what one thing is it
left concrete proof for all of us that
that [ __ ] really did happen yeah you
know man cuz I can kind of like link
back to that era guy yeah that you have
[ __ ] weird yeah you know I mean it
wasn't just something that we just
remembered yeah
and you know [ __ ] Jenny's scene minor
stuff around the house here yeah and
it's not as impressive as it used to be
yes it doesn't last as long as it used
to last yeah it's still weird but it's
like not it's not as earth-shattering as
it was because I've explained it to
myself of what it is yeah
it's science we'll figure it out
eventually yeah physics
so apparently like Jackson and his dudes
have been like sit around in Belle's
house and I guess some of the dudes are
getting like a little cheesed off that
nothing exciting is happening so mr.
which tamer he starts it they've been
there several hours he decides he's
gonna take out his pistol and says I got
a silver bullet in this and any evil
spirit that pops out and we're killing
yeah and then he went on to say that
he's like oh well maybe the reason that
the witch hasn't like popped out in the
last few hours because she's scared of
this [ __ ] she's scared of the witch
tamer with the silver bullet yeah now
right after he said that according to
this harpy he started like jerking
around and screaming and stuff like that
and he said that he felt like he was
being beaten and stuck with pins
by an invisible hand so I guess he
pissed the witch off so witch tamer not
so much also I've seen two versions of
the story one version says that he was
dragged bodily out of the house by his
nose the other version of the story says
that the witch kicked him in the ass and
like kicked him out the door yeah so
apparently the entity then spoke up and
said oh by the way there's another fraud
among your little friends here all if
you hang around until tomorrow night
I'll tell you who the other one is right
now at this point according to the story
Jackson's men are all freaking out and
they all want to leave but Jackson is
curious he's like oh I want to find out
who the other [ __ ] is she's
gonna tell me tomorrow night so we have
to stay but you know but the men so the
Ben's like well we're not sleeping in
the house so they went outside to sleep
in the tents and kept like pastoring him
it's like we really got to get out of
here this [ __ ] isn't cool and all this
other kind of [ __ ] also so finally I
guess he didn't hang around until the
next night because I guess he got tired
of like his men pissing and moaning and
wanting to leave because apparently they
were seen in Springfield the next day
because he had packed up and left
another version of the story said that
after he ended up leaving the farm that
he later said to someone I'd rather
fight the entire British Army than to
deal with the Bell which so apparently
it scared him to but like I said there
are differing versions of that legend
now about this time the youngest
daughter Betsy Bell she starts kind of
getting a romantic interest in this
fellow named Joshua Gardner who also
lived in the same town now they were
actually going to get married but
apparently for whatever reason the Bell
Witch did not want this to happen she
never explained why so pretty much of
the whole so every time like the two of
them would go somewhere like they'd go
down to the cave or they gonna the river
to like have a little date or make out
or whatever it was they were doing the
Bell which would apparently follow them
and like torment them and like yell at
them and kick them and [ __ ] like that
you know what I mean because she didn't
want them to get married for whatever
reason
um so there was also she had an betsy
also had another suitor who was named
Richard Powell now he was her he had
been her schoolteacher
they there was 11 years between them
that wasn't you know that's not really
all that unusual because I think even
John Bell and his wife were had you know
1112 position maybe in 1718 years
between them and there were stories
going around and these might be later
extrapolations that the schoolteacher of
Richard Powell was interested in the
occult as well and maybe that's why he
was interested in Betsy I don't really
know what the whole deal was there there
were also stories that he was secretly
married to someone else
back in Nashville um but I guess Betsy
didn't want to marry him
so that whole thing so because Betsy and
Joshua you know had wanted to get
married but apparently the bill which
just kept [ __ ] with them and
apparently in 1821 Betsy couldn't take
it anymore and she broke off the
engagement with Joshua she's like look
the witch doesn't want it to happen and
I'm just like sick of dealing with this
[ __ ] so we better just break up because
otherwise now after that happened
because apparently that was the bill
witches mission for a while to keep them
from getting married although like I
said I don't know why she wanted that
and she never explained so after the
engagement was broken then apparently
she decided that she was gonna set her
sights on John Bell because now she
suddenly decided she hated his ass and
that she was going to kill him now
through this whole time like I said John
Bell had been suffering from some type
of like I believe it was Bell's palsy or
something similar um you know it's he
was his face would twitch and things
like that kind of like a stroke or
whatnot he couldn't swallow you know
made a hard time swallowing and it
started getting worse and worse now by
the time the fall of 1820 had rolled
around he pretty much couldn't leave the
house he was more or less confined to
his bed and you know couldn't really do
any work in the around the farm anymore
and at this point the Bell which started
like tormenting him like he would be
laying and you know laying on the bed or
sitting down and she would like pull his
shoes off and
around and she would start slapping his
face and she started like saying a bunch
of [ __ ] or like cursing at him and you
know threatening to kill him and all
this other kind of stuff she called him
old Jack Bell supposedly these people
can't see anything there's no apparition
yeah and like I said I don't think they
ever saw its it was always like a
disembodied voice and like you know [ __ ]
happening like [ __ ] flying around and I
was like that
nobody ever reported like seeing a ghost
or any more of that nature how are we
doing on time towards the we're probably
the 1 hour mark
probably yeah we are yeah 54 minutes
okay you want to take a break yeah it's
going to take a break all right so we
are going to take a break right now when
we get back we will talk about the death
of John Bell we're talking about some of
these subsequent stories about the Bell
Witch and where some of this stuff might
have come from so hang in there for just
a few minutes and we will be back in
just a moment what's up you guys
so are you arguing
are you having that argument hey stop it
what happened pokey did she yell at you
yeah did she yell at you what do you
guys if I didn't know what are you
fighting about
what is it Beijing does she make you mad
does she make you mad my man she mad at
you yeah you're not a lot concerned
about it so clearly okay go to your
corners
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry baby's case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back now when we know of
course the yeah the kitty has a minute
scratch on the chair she's like you guys
are not paying enough attention to me
yes you may
so when we last left we were talking
about John Bell getting tormented in his
final illness by the Bell which now
apparently his illness was getting worse
and worse on December 19th 1820 he went
into a coma and on the following day he
died now according to the legend
shortly after John Bell died his family
discovered a vial of like some
unidentified smoky liquid in a cupboard
and none of them knew where it had come
from so they were kind of curious about
what this was so apparently the son John
Bell jr. put like a straw in there and
took a couple drops out and gave a drop
or two to a cat which dropped dead in a
couple of minutes that's not in all
versions of the story though no it's not
in all those so but that's in the most
common version so apparently at this
stage they're like oh well presumably
John Bell was poisoned and then the Bell
which supposedly spoke up and said I
gave old jack a big dose of that last
night which fixed him yeah yeah so then
like some versions of the story to say
that then the son then threw the vial
into the fireplace and at this big blue
flame shot out of it and like up the
chimney
now John bells funeral is also another
thing that happens in the legend in one
version of the story Kate Kate as we'll
get into that that's what they ended up
calling her that she kept singing songs
over the preacher that was overseeing
the funeral so it was like drowning him
out the most common version of the story
though is that after the funeral was
over and everyone was leaving the
graveyard she started singing like
drinking songs and [ __ ] like that like
almost like mocking the fact that he was
dead so apparently John Bell being
killed by the witch
supposedly
was kind of like that was her final
mission in life because there wasn't a
lot of reported activity after he died
so the next report of it actually is
from April of 1821 when apparently the
Bell which visited lucy-belle John bells
Widow and said I'm going away now but I
will come back for a visit in seven
years now according to the story the
witch did come back in 1828 which was
seven years later and visited with Lucy
and also visited with the son John Bell
Jr and apparently the two of them had
some really nice discussions about
various topics you know religion and you
know other types of things and
apparently also at this meeting the Bell
which made some predictions about future
events such as the outcome of the civil
war among other things and apparently
they turned out to be true so the witch
things the story written so this is like
yeah so apparently this time the which
hung around for three weeks at which
point she said okay well I'm leaving now
again
but I will visit your most direct
descendant in a hundred and seven years
why hundred and seven I don't know
because there's a hundred that's a lot
yeah seven made that [ __ ] holy and
complete yeah what I guess and said 100
and said a [ __ ] ton of them
with God's permission it makes perfect
sense so in this year which would have
been 1935 the closest living relative of
John Bell who's alive at that time was a
physician by the name of dr. Charles
Bailey Bell who lived in Nashville now
he actually ended up writing a book
about the Bell which himself which he
published in 1934 the year before the
witch showed up but he never did publish
a follow up saying you know the witch
totally came and visited me I think so
presumably she did not so to this day
the Bell Witch phenomena although much
depleted is said to continue now the
house is no longer there all that's left
you can still go there if you ask
permission cuz the end that the land is
privately owned but there's apparently
like some a little bit of cement and
like some beams and [ __ ] like that like
down on the ground
however there is the Bell Witch cave
which did figure a little bit in some
versions of the legend and I believe for
a while it you know the land like I said
is privately owned for a while they only
opened the cave to tourists on Halloween
like are right around October I think
now they do it pretty much all the time
so you can go there and pay for a ticket
and like hang out in the end of cave and
apparently some people have you know
heard things seeing things it felt like
they were being breathed on or punched
or whatever one it probably one of the
most famous cases from back then about
the Bell Witch cave was that there was a
little boy playing in there I don't know
if he was related to the bells or just
like a friend of theirs and he got I've
heard two versions of the story it's
like either got an ankle stuck between
two rocks or his head stuck between two
rocks which I'm not really sure how you
managed that but apparently he was like
calling for help and Kate pulled him out
by his feet so like rescued him so like
I said she's a little bit of a so you
know some people she's nice to and some
people she's shitty to I guess that's
like where this whole thing so like I
said the town of Adam's Tennessee they
still very much you know that's probably
their main tourist thing is the Bell
Witch thing they have Bell Witch cave
still that you can go visit every
October since 2002 they do a play that's
called spirit that's based on the Bell
Witch legend and they have like a whole
Bell Witch festival and like so
everything so they do it right now for
like you know tourists kind of things
because it's kind of like a really small
town I think there's only like 600
something people living there so you
know but so let's talk a little bit
about it's not about dates huh where
this story came from where and when are
we talking about well because here's the
deal yeah you go online and yo you're
your
the same Bell Witch legend over and over
again and it stated as as if it's well
documented fact and that everybody
agrees that this is what happened and
when but then when you look at the time
line involved yeah they had to start
kind of breaking down necessarily the
case because most of these stories and
books come from like 70 years after it
they said that it happened yeah
and whenever some [ __ ] like that goes
down man
where's this information coming from
yeah that's kind of what I feel like
okay so I'm not gonna because most
versions of the story the most popular
version of the story pretty much every
version of it the people know most of
the main sourcing comes from Martin
Ingram's book the authenticated history
of the Bell Witch which was published in
1894 now this book was supposedly based
on the journal or the diary of one of
the Bell sons who was six years old at
the alleged time of the disturbances but
did not write it down until thirty years
later also Martin Ingram said that okay
well he gave me this diary but I
promised that I wouldn't publish a book
about the Bell which until all of the
immediate family members were dead which
is why he took until 1894 supposedly to
write the book about it
now I should note that although I think
a lot of this story is fabricated
most of the people involved in it are
real people there are records of the
bells I mean there were a real family
there's you know are their records so
then back in the day having a
poltergeist problem see that's the issue
okay not that I know of all right
however there was so it could be a
writer a fiction writer talking about
people who really lived but he had to
wait to them he had to wait for them all
to die before he could actually I know
but now I'm not saying that he made it
up out of whole cloth because
there were stories about the Bell which
circulating like 50 years after the
facts 4050 years after the fact so it's
like so there were like little Inklings
of it but a lot of this stuff like juice
best stuff about Andrew Jackson the
stuff about the witch killing John Bell
a lot of those details were not in the
really early accounts you know what I'm
saying like some of the like early
accounts and even these like I said were
40 50 years after the incidents
allegedly took place most of them were
just like oh there was this mischievous
spirit in the house and everybody kind
of heard about it and it used to like
spill the milk and throw [ __ ] and it
didn't say anything about beating anyone
up or killing anyone or Andrew Jackson
visiting or anything like that like all
of those details were kind of like added
later on you know what I'm saying now as
far as I know the earliest published
mention and fergan you know correct me
if I'm wrong about this was in 1856
which if you will note because these the
manifestations supposedly occurred
starting in 1817 and then mostly stopped
when John Bell died in 1820 you know
what I mean he wrote about it in 56
that's a long this is not the book
either this is apparently there was an
article that turned up and it's
unattributed there's no author on this
article but there was an article that
appeared in February January February
1856 that was published in the New
England farmer of Boston which was like
a Farmers Almanac type like a weekly
publication and then there was a Vermont
paper called the Green Mountain Freeman
which was like the newspaper put out by
the like the abolitionist movement it
was they owned it so these kind of gave
a little bit of a rundown of the Bell
Witch legend now they said though that
we got this story from The Saturday
Evening Post who published an article I
believe in 18-49 about the witch however
in this article so I've read because no
one knows if this article exists okay
the article that supposedly appeared in
the Saturday evening or was written for
this
Saturday Evening Post and was not
published because that's something that
Martin Ingram said later on supposedly
said yeah there was all this weird
phenomenon going on at the Bell family
farm but that it was Betsy doing it like
that she was faking you know what I mean
hmm um so apparently this article was
written for The Saturday Evening Post
that essentially said that according to
Martin Ingraham later the guy who wrote
the book later on he said oh well they
decided not to publish because some of
the family members were going to sue for
libel because they were saying that
Betsy had invented the poltergeist
phenomena like that she was doing it in
order to get Joshua to marry or not
marry or something like that there was
like some kind of big [ __ ] story about
it so so as far as I know 1856 this
article came and like I said I don't
know where they got the story from
supposedly was from The Saturday Evening
Post but no one has ever been able to
find the original Saturday Evening Post
article so I don't know if it just if it
was really written and then it was
scrapped like Martin Ingraham said but
modern researchers have said you know
The Saturday Evening Post kept very good
records and they have all of the
articles from back then you know but you
know I mean they've I think they've
almost all been put online or you can at
least get them unlike microfiche and
stuff and they're like they never found
anything like that and they're like if
we couldn't find it I don't know how he
would have found it you know what I'm
saying
so I don't so those days research was
even harder yeah that's what I mean so
I'm not sure I'm not saying that he just
made it up or he's a liar or anything
like that but I'm just saying maybe he
just maybe somebody just told him oh
well I wrote an article for The Saturday
Evening Post saying this that the other
was ever published and maybe maybe the
post threatened to write that article
and then and then the family boy it's so
like there's no way of knowing because
it would all be just like hearsay and
everyone's dead at this point anyway now
it should be noted that in this very
first mention she has not called the
Bell which she's usually called the Bell
ghost or the Tennessee ghost and this
article says yeah this should happen 30
years ago so the first published mention
is from many years later already okay so
an article mentioned it said yeah 30
years ago this [ __ ] fish
but what did they say happened they
basically just said that when you would
put the lights out in the house at night
then this voice would start talking okay
the person who wrote the article and
like I said the person was not named the
article didn't have a name on it they
said that they were friends with Joshua
Gardner who had been the guy who was
engaged to marry Betsy Bell now pretty
much like I said all the article said
was that just there was you know so
there that there was poltergeist
activity that there was a voice that
would happen like in the dark and that
someone asked the ghost how long are you
going to hang around and the ghost
reportedly said until Joshua Gardner and
Betsy Bell get married now this article
also said that Betsy Bell or implied
that Betsy Bell was using quote/unquote
ventriloquism in order to maybe to get
Joshua Gardner to marry her let me back
up yeah so the article said 30 years ago
something happened at this location
there was a voice yeah the voice said it
will be here until these two get married
all right now you said poltergeist
phenomena they said poltergeist
phenomena or they say objects moving
what did they say I think actually that
might have happened a little bit later I
don't know if they mention it because I
didn't find like the whole entire
article basically it just talked about
the voice there was some [ __ ] about
poltergeist phenomena later I don't
think they used that word but they but
they did mention something like in a
short paragraph in like a later history
of the area about kind of like [ __ ]
moving this is kind of striking me in a
certain way the original aparts and it's
these are old reports out yeah yeah of
what the original phenomenon was
actually sounds kind of plausible you
might have a young girl just kind of
like Janet Hobson from you know this
from from Enfield poltergeist
maybe she's young she's kind of going
through puberty she really wants to get
married really badly she starts
manifesting poltergeist phenomena right
and in this case there's a voice know
Janet
Janet's poltergeist had a voice but the
voice came out of her own voice box the
voice of a man
you know you can there's recordings of
it it's pretty odd yeah but it's kind of
more like imagine some people might say
well that's possession no more like what
if it's a person who's in a trance okay
kind of exhibiting psychokinesis and
speaking in tongues that'd be something
from the church we call it speaking in
tongues yeah which is you know you have
kind of like voices from the
subconscious you know alter egos and
stuff making proclamations trying to
make this marriage happen because
important back then yeah maybe she
wanted out of the house so actually the
the very first mention of the phenomenon
makes me think that maybe something did
happen yeah although like I said I was
pretty minor yeah I believe and like I
said I don't have the original I don't
have the text of the original thing I've
only had like someone else's summary of
it I believe the implication in the
early article was that Betsy was faking
yeah that she was throwing her voice
assent but they also accused Jim Hobson
yeah I'm just saying that I know that a
real case based upon just how many damn
witnesses saw it and what the phenomena
they were reported it wasn't just that
voice that was coming out of it was also
all those moving objects that they
couldn't explain yeah which I've seen
that kind of stuff myself you know so
I'm just saying that the the story of
the Bell Witch may be a fabrication laid
over something that really did happen
yeah that's yeah because I'm not saying
that that's why I'm saying that you know
most of the you know really outlandish
stuff I think I know about the Bell
Witch that probably just came from that
one guy's book yeah he wrote a book
about it
they made a Blair Witch style book yeah
you know what I mean something that was
sensational but the legend itself was
not unheard of when he wrote a book
about it there had been like talk about
it but it wasn't as but a lot of the
crazier details yeah because the
original report doesn't mention anything
about a dog with a with with a rabbit
head yeah learn in any of these long
convoluted story
is about people being poisoned by ghosts
or any of that [ __ ] yeah that was all
that sounds like somebody got a hold of
a poltergeist story of something that
really happened but it wasn't quite good
enough and years later they had to sexy
had a sex that [ __ ] up into a
best-selling novel I kind of suspect
this I kind of suspect we're looking at
a situation that's analogous to like the
Amityville like the Amityville Horror
where something shitty and terrible did
happen at that house a whole family was
murdered in that house that is not in
dispute yeah but I think a lot of the
[ __ ] that happened you know that they
said happened later all the paranormal
stuff I think that was largely invented
I'm pretty sure and I'm pretty sure that
this might be the case here I'm not
saying that there wasn't some minor
poltergeist activity that people heard
about you know and I'm she might have
been faking to I don't know
but now the Amityville case you know the
little son grew up and I don't really
believe what he says yeah the adult
Lutz's George Lutz said some stuff and
maybe there's something to it if they
moved if they moved into that Amityville
house after that murder it was probably
a pretty damn creepy house I would think
maybe they did see a few things but then
later that book deal got side to they
became that's what I mean and had the
damn you had the damn [ __ ] our to our
favorite couple there yeah the warrants
the Warrens yeah the Warrens show up and
of course and I don't ever they get
involved you know add to a well because
like I said I think from their point of
view they just they want to get their
message of like you know demons and we
need to do something about it because
they're you know they're hardcore
Christians and everything so I feel like
they I feel like they they don't feel
like they're lying any other way in the
flames of anything that was going on
sure that make it bigger than it was
yeah so yeah you might be dealing with a
similar situation
kind of like an Amityville type
situation where there might be something
at its core but then some guys that want
to sell a book or make a movie get
involved and then if I could blow it all
out of proportion yeah because like I
said you know eat
you can't make like a boring book it's
like people still wanna you know and the
funny thing is about the the later bail
which case of what they're talking about
all the phenomena you could tell that
they borrowed from the great cases of
the past
yeah old demonology books maybe some
stuff from spiritualism you know and
seances and maybe a few poltergeist
cases yeah they're borrowing phenomenon
from across the board to make a big
story yeah definitely yeah but now you
might find this interesting so now
several years before the famous red book
came out Martin Ingram's book there was
a book published in 1886 which was
called the history of Tennessee which
was written by the Goodspeed Brothers
now in this book you know it was a
history of Tennessee so it wasn't about
all about ghosts or anything like that
however there was a paragraph or two and
they're mentioning the Bell Witch legend
and I actually do have the text of this
because this is in the public domain and
it basically said a remarkable
occurrence and keep in mind this was
published in 1886 a remarkable
occurrence which attracted widespread
interest was connected with the family
of John Bell who settled near what is
now Adams station about 1804 so great
was the excitement that people came from
hundreds of miles around to witness the
manifestations of what was popularly
known as the Bell which as far as I know
this is the first time that it's called
the Bell which yes yeah go back and tell
us those dates again this is 84 and
they're talking about wind to that uh
606 1886 this is published and they're
talking about 1800 well they're actually
talking about 1817 to 1820 that's when
these manifestations are the bells moved
to Tennessee in eighteen so they're
talking about something that happened
like 70 years ago yeah yeah um the way
that's that's there's a lot of room
there yeah yeah that's a long time
that's a lifetime that yet and in those
days with the limitations of that era
you could say anything yeah
seventy years yeah and like I said this
is just a mention like in a Tennessee
history book yeah they just mentioned it
so and as far as I know like I said this
is the first time in public that you
know in a publication that it was called
the Bell which this which was supposed
to be some spiritual being having the
voice and attributes of a woman it was
invisible to the eye yet it would hold
conversation and even shake hands with
certain individuals the freaks it
performed were wonderful and seemingly
designed to annoy the family it would
take the sugar from the bowls spill the
milk take the quilts from the bed slap
and pinch the children and then laugh at
the discomfiture of its victims
at first it was supposed to be a good
spirit but its subsequent acts together
with the curses with which it
supplemented its remarks proved the
contrary a volume might be written
concerning the performances of this
wonderful being as they are now
described by contemporaries and their
descendants that all this actually
occurred will not be disputed nor will
the rational explanation be attempted it
won't be disputed yes it won't be
disputed it is merely introduced as an
example of superstition strong in the
minds of all but a few in those times
and not yet wholly extinct I think
they're talking about a real poltergeist
case but they just laid it on thick
probably yeah I don't think you could
shake hands with wand yeah I mean Louis
says she felt it come up out of the
floor and remember that circle around
her leg and then around her waist and
then just kind of vanished she just kind
of fell what'd she say said just kind of
felt like a cold kind of a hand but I
watched that happen I was standing right
in front I didn't see anything to press
in on her yeah you know I mean yeah he
didn't have any substance yeah she's
just whoa I didn't know what was
happening and she cuz it test me all
right so I didn't see anything sneaking
around her yeah dude I didn't see
clothing depress or anything so well
like I said so much of it is like
subjective yeah there's a lot of stuff
you know during ours to where your
feelings of being watched to whatever
that means I don't know how that works
how did how you feel like you're being
watched and then feelings of I felt like
it was real cold but it wasn't like a
normal temperature cold yeah it's just
I don't know like some kind of energy
being sucked out of you weird there's a
lot of things that happened weird that
that you don't know if it was just you
know I mean it's difficult to describe
yeah and then objects would move weird
but I don't think you could shake hands
with it and it did kind of speak that
one time but it wasn't coherent yeah it
was [ __ ] spooky every hair on my head
[ __ ] stood up it was in that [ __ ]
on that mattress or now the mattress was
on that fold-out caught in that sleeping
bag yeah the guests kind of man that I
told Louis about it in recent times and
she says yes I thought it was like the
water going through pipes where the
toilet was in the room next door mm-hmm
because on the other side of that wall
would have been about where the toilet
was yeah and she said like she says you
know it did kind of make noises every
now and then over there
but then when I kind of mimics the sound
that it makes you is that she was like
now did release it didn't sound like
that because I don't think I told her in
detail of what I'd actually heard at
that time yeah a lot of times you just
want to kind of stay silent about
something because if you talked about
something too long it would start doing
what it was you were talking about yeah
so if you mention the things that
frightened you a lot if it might start
doing what frighten do a lot so it's
best to just yeah yeah yes - like not
mention certain things it just it
followed your lead it had an
intelligence to it yeah weird now there
was also another several page account of
the legend now this was actually
published in 1900 although it had
supposedly been written in 1880
although the author is uncredited this
was actually like put in a book that was
kind of about Robertson County where
Adams is and was supposedly written for
Nashville's Centennial Exposition which
took place in 1880
now the person that
it said that they had got like witness
testimony from people who were around at
the time including Benjamin batts who
was a real person and we'll kind of get
into that a little bit later because
he's kind of important to the story and
this is where the aspect of the story
about there were there was a skull like
found in a like a mound like near the
river bluff like nearby and that's what
they thought was causing the
disturbances however when they you know
dug up the skull and gave it a Christian
burial or whatever it didn't make it go
away
this account also said that the witch
spoke in several different languages as
far as I know that's the first you know
iteration of that fact and would you
know set dogs on people and also it
seems like this is the first mention of
John Bell being poisoned by the witch
like this whole poison story where they
found the poison even though in later
iterations it seemed like it was found
in a cupboard in this story it was found
in the chimney flue you know what I mean
this lit this little bottle yeah and and
in this story it did say that the witch
said I put the poison there with you
know I was going to kill John Bell with
it but I guess they didn't get to it or
something like that but apparently the
witch said that she put it in the couple
different stories that's what I mean so
that's this seems to be the first as far
as I know this is the first published
reference to the poison bottle when you
have a couple of different stories
especially this later on this so late in
the game after the [ __ ] thing
happened and this is the first time it's
mentioned and tell you that that's it's
one author copy and another one yeah and
I feel like that's kind of the case but
it's but like I said I think that's why
this case has always been so interesting
to me because you can see how details
got added like as the years went on
they're building a legend yeah
definitely and this one also this
particular account which like I said
supposedly written in 1880 but not
published until 1900 this one also said
that the witch could shape-shift that
she could appear as a bear a black dog
or a rabbit that she could make a bunch
of different animal sounds
this one also kind of like and it's
interesting because I have in our
bedroom I have like a bill which poster
my friend gave it to me a long time ago
pretty cool it's from a place called
Madame talbe
Madame Talbots Victorian lowbrow like
she makes like all kind of really cool
posters and [ __ ] like that and it's Bell
Witch and it has like all these little
Scrolls that say different things that
say like mathematics and black dog and
stuff like that the reason that it says
that is because in this particular
account and as far as I know this first
time this is mentioned that there's like
a family that there wasn't just one
ghost it was a whole family of them and
those were their names black dog
mathematics mathematics Sybok Rafi and
Jerusalem were like the names of these
of these spirits black dog was
supposedly the leader of this group of
spirit so it wasn't just one that
Zeppelin was talking about I guess so
apparently there were like some other
stories that were published around 1890
not that were like not necessarily to do
with although it was kind of attributed
to the Bell which you know just because
like crazy [ __ ] would happen and they
feel like yeah I heard a voice like
going like haha you know you've been
bewitched which is what I imagined she
would say like some one guy said that he
was um like trying to put a sack of corn
like on his horse and it kept falling
off and other stuff and then like he
heard a voice and stuff and telling him
the youth like you won't touch the bag
anymore because it kept falling off the
horse name she kept trying to put it
back on apparently there was also an
article published in February of 1890
where the they published some stories
about some Bell Witch adjacent type of
stories but they kind of subtitled it
more tales of a fishy flavor yeah so I
feel like they kind of like knew that
these were tall tales maybe well it's
probably starting to fall into the
category of like airship sightings yeah
which you know not to [ __ ] on airship
sightings I think some of the airship
sightings might have been what you would
call UFO sighting it today yeah other
ones are total cure fabrications yeah
because
you know newspapers of those days you
know this is the [ __ ] deepest the
deepest [ __ ] era of yellow journalism
you know the whole idea was just to sell
newspapers and then then do the [ __ ]
telling the truth which that's starting
to come back actually if you look at the
news now they'll tell you anything but
in those days they would write up a good
airship story and the authors just
assumed that you were in on the joke I
think that happened a lot because I
think this was kind of like I don't even
know I don't know like I wasn't around
at the time so like I don't really even
know if they publish stuff go and let's
see what these rubes will believe or if
they just publish stuff with the
knowledge that most people would know
that it was just a story I think they
were [ __ ] with you
ya knew that you were liking this [ __ ]
and that you and that you knew that it
was fake I kind of feel like it's maybe
it was sort of like you know how the old
Weekly World News used to be it's like I
don't really think other than like you
know the fringe of crazy people I don't
think anybody that was buying that
really believed that hey that [ __ ] was
true right that you know alien babies
you know I said you know what my fate my
very favorite Edison aliens I still
remember my very favorite headline from
that I even bought the issue zone like
50 cents or something at the time I even
bought it because I liked it so much
chocoholic mom gives birth to
sugar-coated babies I'm like oh I gotta
have that right but if there's a lot of
that that's maybe it so I feel like some
of the newspapers from back in the day
might have been the airship laborers
were you know airship flies over the
town you know and they hear the men
working on it and yelling you know just
like they're on a ship and it they drop
an anchor and in the anchor comes down
and it hits the ground and a guy comes
down the anchor and ask for some water
you give us some water parts and then
they say that they're on their way to
Philadelphia and they'll be there in a
few hours and you know come on they're
not talking about aliens yeah they're
talking about human beings flying a
[ __ ] huge ass [ __ ] Zeppelin the
size of the Titanic yeah before those
things existed
so they could invent one of those but
they couldn't even think to bring what
their own water so they didn't have
their own water working head steam power
and they're like Oh water I need some
water
the most actually it was tea they wanted
some tea Oh coffee
oh well la-dee-da yeah fan they're
making [ __ ] up
we're you know what a crazy thing to
make up there I mean it's funny because
it seems weird to us now like you know
what I mean it's you like this whole
airship sighting thing but this [ __ ]
goes in cycles like it seems weird to us
now because we don't have the cultural
context yeah of what was going on at the
time like it wouldn't have been weird
for them at the time back in in the
interstate understood it because they
air flight was coming
yeah and that was just you know they
were they were super [ __ ] impressed
they couldn't wait for flight to come
yeah I know and yeah balloons and
saplings were kind of progressing faster
than airplanes you know this is before
the Wright brothers a lot that they're
talking about a lot of this stuff so
they assumed that you know giant
airships would be the first thing that
they would see right I was you know so
they're just like jumping the gun
they're jumping the gun although
airships did did [ __ ] appear you know
in the thirties they did yeah they were
huge
yeah and it's strange that they don't
use them anymore I mean things the size
a dam shopping centers flying yeah
filled with people they're dangerous as
[ __ ] well that's probably why then you
ask them anymore but I would imagine
that with today's technology you could
get it done yeah but it's just at this
point you have every all this other [ __ ]
and it just seems like why bother you
know what I mean well an airship case a
[ __ ] extreme heavy lift vehicle you
can pick up pick up a lot of weight with
that yeah it's not fast but you can move
it across the sky like a luxury liner so
you could live in one for months that'd
be kind of neat yeah go on a long
journey you know but you know they don't
go very high yeah although they didn't
back then you probably could do it now
oh yeah you could do it now yeah
probably so you could fly above the
weather you know that's the thing
well yeah that's what planes gonna do
you want to fly above the weather make
it a lot safer yeah so apparently
another one of these stories because
like I said there were a bunch of
different stories that came out in 1890
about like I said not necessarily about
the Bell which like sometimes they
didn't name it by they didn't say Bell
which sometimes she said though which or
you know in that area so I assumed that
people would know what they were talking
about so these kind of Bell Witch
adjacent stories although like I said a
lot of them were published under this
sort of like wink-wink nudge-nudge kind
of subtitle however one of these stories
which I really enjoyed and I'm sure it
didn't happen but it's just like I just
really like this story so it was a guy
named mr. winters that's all he's named
as and this is kind of going back to the
origin of the legend where apparently
the John valve jr. like saw a really big
weird bird that he didn't like never
kind of he'd seen before and so
apparently mr. winters here he sees a
weird big bird and but he shoots it and
he puts it in his game bag however when
he gets home and opens the game bag the
bird is not there and then there's a
rabbit in there but then the rabbit
disappears yeah also later on apparently
the same guy no this is a different guy
actually
so this different guy named mr. Roland
he reported that he was out in his yard
at nine o'clock one night like burning
some you know trash or whatever and this
black man with one eye in the middle
whose forehead came up to him and told
him that he had to go like follow me to
this big rock and you have to dig there
and then he disappeared so apparently
mr. Rowland goes and dug that night and
they found like black Cyclops
yeah and he was like a snake that's the
first time I've ever heard of a black
yeah so he started well here's the thing
he starts digging in here and he's just
digs in day so he's tired then he gets
his friend in there to dig and they just
keep digging they found something that
they described as quote unquote a kettle
turned bottom upward which doesn't sound
all that exciting then they were trying
to take it out but they claimed that
they couldn't do it because the hole
kept filling itself back in with dirt so
it's a weird report that's what I mean
it's like who the [ __ ] what kind of
drugs were they uh I don't get it
that's just an eighteen hundreds [ __ ]
imagined perineal paranormal phenomena
yeah it's like that's crazy so that's
not that crazy and I think think of the
Japanese I mean they you know they had
[ __ ] thing paranormal monsters like
umbrellas that had that could fly and
their tongues hung out and they have
Jonah one eye one foot yeah that they
just hopped around on one leg with an
umbrella yeah you know you go like what
kind of crazy [ __ ] is that made sense
back in those days that's what I mean we
don't have the context it's just names
weird now because it now much like
almost playing the audience why that
[ __ ] make it up now that they were
called yeah if you see any of them like
on yokai monsters they say yokai monster
you're like what the [ __ ] is that an
umbrella with a single eye and a mouth
of the big old tongue and ass one leg
trying to kill people it's because the
Japanese were animists they believe that
the old or something got that there'd be
a chance that it might come to life
right kind of like an ancient not really
all that ancient but just a kind of an
an antique Japanese theory of evolution
yeah it says what it was
well the oldest thing in the jet yeah
average Japanese household was a [ __ ]
umbrella because they were old yeah
these are expensive so you kept them
around you know the longer they were
around them you think you might think
that it might come alive yeah all the
thing in your house is damn umbrella
you're worried about it [ __ ] Mike Mike
it's weird though if they thought that
like why they didn't think like all of
their [ __ ] would come to life like did
they oh my god that teacup he's become
animus yeah they don't have like a yokai
monster looks like a teacup do they with
a foot because the umbrella would be
older okay yeah but I'm just saying it's
a good weight at some point you would
think at some point the teacup head
would have to be old enough to like come
to life just right just just by that
much 1800s Japanese thinking I'm just
okay yeah I'll just seventeen in
eighteen how to cope raghava period
japanese thinking yeah everything
so as I mentioned before probably the
origin of most of the popular Bell Witch
stories is Martin Ingram's book the
authenticated history of the Bell Witch
which came out in 1894 now as I
mentioned before this supposedly was
based on a diary by one of the young
sons of the bells who had been six years
old at the time of the disturbances
allegedly but didn't write them down
until 30 years later gave the diary to
will actually gave the diary to someone
else like his older brothers cousin or
something who then subsequently gave it
to Martin Ingram allegedly and then
Martin Ingram said well I'm gonna write
a book about it but not until after all
of the immediate family members are dead
so so I don't get in trouble or you know
or whatever so this book is known as the
red book like I said this is the one
that I read growing up because my
grandparents had it um it's kind of like
it's it's kind of a hard read because
it's in this very flowery prose you know
what I mean they used to how they used
to write it so it's kind of like hard to
follow but pretty much all of your you
know popular Bell Witch stories come
from pretty much this single source now
the problem is that some of the stuff
that he says in that book and I'll get
into this a little bit later but some of
the [ __ ] that he says in that book is
demonstrably not true like you know what
I mean like um for example the stuff
about Andrew Jackson yeah it couldn't
happen
I'm visiting there they're like look
it's like he was a major general at the
time his whereabouts were were known at
the time that the you know in 1819 when
he was supposed to have visited develop
farm and they're like yes he did own
land in that area I think that he did
own some land in that area but they're
pretty sure that he couldn't have been
there when it was said that yeah added
that part an element to the story to add
credibility to the story yeah because
like oh it's a famous person yes so you
have to be a very suspect when an author
does that yeah yeah it definitely is but
there are like a lot of historical
inaccuracies and that and as I said this
is
is this happening this is where you're
being told this 70 years after it
happened yeah and even and even if he's
using because we were talking before and
I saw this on like a Bell Witch
documentary that I was watching where
they had a woman who was a skeptic and
she was talking about the Blair Witch
Project being found footage and she
suspects that the authenticated history
of the Bell Witch might also be like an
early form of found footage in the sense
that he's writing from a diary write
that supposedly was from somebody that
was there but didn't write it down till
30 years later but no one has ever seen
this diary significantly footage so we
don't actually know if this diary exists
because no one has ever produced it now
you would think that if it really
existed that the author of the book
Martin Ingram would have published it or
would have like publicized it you know
what I mean if that's when he was basing
it on but he didn't do that no it's not
to say that the original incident didn't
happen right I think something maybe
happened yeah then later on somebody
does a Blair Witch Project spin yeah
where it's like oh I found many years
later Dyer oh I found this diary or
someone gave it to me yeah and let me
tell you what it says yeah and he writes
his story like I said that was a pretty
popular literary device I'm pretty like
like a gothic fiction and Victorian era
fiction goes back to where it is Dracula
yeah well yeah it's like earlier in the
letters where it's like yeah it's like
oh I found like a you know a manuscript
in a bottle and this is what it said you
know it's like a frame story like a
round a story and it gives it more
credibility because it makes it seem
real historical because it's like oh
well I could be in the attic and I could
find like an old manuscript and you know
I mean so it kind of gives it that air
of veracity
yeah Eaters of the Dead was like that
yeah and I feel like in 13th warrior
yeah that movie wasn't wasn't that like
an honor whether or not maybe not
Robinson Crusoe maybe that's not what
I'm thinking of but it's something else
where it was like a you know a
manuscript that was like found were a
lot more sophisticated back then people
think you know they didn't have any
laptops or didn't movies to speak they'd
never knows movies really they had plays
and
press the main form of entertainment
were these books yeah and you better
know how to write yeah so they knew how
to play all the games back then nothing
to do and like and like you said there
was a lot of this kind of [ __ ] going on
yeah they were already doing it so like
I said most of the main [ __ ] like all
the main details of the you know Bell
Witch legend kind of come from Martin
Ingram's book now as I said there was
another book that came out who from
someone who was actually a direct
descendant even though obviously he
wasn't alive at the time all this was
neither was martin ingram wasn't alive
when all this [ __ ] was going on either
in 1934 dr. Charles Bailey Bell who I
mentioned before he was a doctor in
Nashville and a direct descendant of
John Bell he wrote a book called the
Bell which a mysterious spirit published
in 1934 now his book was essentially a
less flowery retelling of Martin
Ingram's book although there were a
couple of differences like he tended to
he really but like pumped up John bells
reputation more like he spent a lot of
the book like talking about what an
awesome dude he was and stuff which I'll
get into the reason that he might have
done that later on because I kind of
want to talk about that movie in
American haunting and because there's
some [ __ ] in there that I kind of want
to get into so he kind of like what
overboard and like talking about what a
wonderful man he was and he was just
like unimpeachable and stuff like that
he was also the one that added the
details about the witch saying that she
would come back later on and then she
came back later on and had discussions
with John Bell Jr in which he predicted
various things so that what I don't
believe that was in Martin Ingram's
original book but that was in Charles
Baillie Bell's book which came out in
the 1930s so that was where that detail
came from that book is known as the
black book like I said we had the red
book I don't think I had the black one
but so now let's talk I want to talk a
little bit about the movie and American
haunting this is one of the many many
movies based on the Bell Witch legend
another one that I watched today which I
do not recommend was just called the
Bell Witch haunting I believe it's from
2013 and it was found footage but it was
set in the
day like of somebody that apparently
built their house everywhere the bill
thing was and then it was like it was
like a paranormal activity ripoff and it
was terrible but this movie in American
haunting I think came out in 2005-2006
had some big names in it Donald
Sutherland was in it as John Bell [ __ ]
Spacek was Lucy Bell and this was pretty
much even though there was like a little
wraparound story of like a modern modern
day it was only like maybe five comprise
five minutes of the movie but most of it
was a pretty standard like retelling of
the Bell Witch legend however it did
have an aspect and I thought that the
movie had just invented this but
apparently there have been like a bunch
of other writers that have written about
the Bell Witch legend that think that
this is like their theory about why if
there was really poltergeist activity
why would have happened so in an
American haunting it ends up being that
Betsy Bell is causing the poltergeist
activity because she is being molested
by her father and like I said I thought
that was something that they just came
up with for the movie but apparently
that's been like kind of a theory that's
been circulating in Bell Witch circles
you know that are saying like if the
poltergeist activity did occur at the
time that speculated maybe that was why
that maybe he'd been sexually abusing
her and it was cut and she was like
acting up because of that yeah some of
the stuff that I remember reading back
in the 80s I think he came from some of
those books in the 1800's that actually
kind of implied that the witch kept
beating him up because of that cause of
improprieties with the daughter
yeah so that's apparently something
that's been circulating would say that
it was that it was kind of crushing his
spirit and that you know it was given
all his secrets even to like to
everybody that came to the house
including like the clergy people yeah
you know it all is it's a tale I'll tell
you that I mean the thing is it's like
yeah not in the original in the original
accounts yeah
where's this coming from I mean you
could well like I said I can see where
that theoretically could come right
some [ __ ] like this those [ __ ]
better be dead before you right that's
what I mean it's like they were saying
that way yeah there's like no way of
proving it at this stage because
everyone is dead and like you know the
thing about it is that a lot of the Bell
family's descendants are still alive and
still live in the Adams Tennessee area I
mean it's a very small town and it's
like there's only like a handful of
different families that live there at
the time and a lot of their descendants
are still there another thing that they
kind of got into and I didn't even
really bring this up very much but this
is part of the original legend at times
the Bell which is known as Kate or Kate
batts now the reason for this is it's
not unclear but the problem was okay
Kate batts who's actually named
Katharine or Katie with a see instead of
Kate with a que Kate with a que that was
like a later spelling
she was actually a real person she did
exist she was actually I believe she was
Lucy bells nice but she was married -
she was married to the brother of
someone that had like a beef with with
John Bell at some point so what ends up
happening in a lot of versions of the
legend is that Kate batts she was um as
far as I know from actual real like
historical documentation at the time she
was kind of she wasn't a witch but she
was like eccentric she was kind of an
eccentric woman like she would roll up
to church with her three sleeves like
her retinue and apparently she was like
mouthy you know what I mean kind of
pushy obnoxious so but like I said she
was a real person she did live around
that town so I think what ended up
happening was that over time the story
arose that her and John Bell had some
kind of beef and that she either
bewitched him or bewitched his family or
sent a demon to like torment the family
or that she was a ghost coming back to
haunt them which would have been hard
for her to do because she outlived Sean
Bell by 23 years she outlived Lucy Bell
as well I think how this ended up
happening one Kate batts was you know
like I said she was known as something
of an eccentric she was also some
that ran a farm on her own because her
husband was disabled which was something
that a lot of women didn't do at the
time so it was seen as unusual like I
said she was very mouthy kind of
obnoxious um you know and so she kind of
stood out in the small town so I think
there was that whole thing also I think
a lot of people and they did this in an
American haunting too they they messed
it up they said that there was like that
she felt like her and her husband got
cheated on a land deal by John Bell and
that that was why she ended up cursing
the family that's not actually what
happened and like I said I'm going back
to like actual records like Church
minutes like you know court records [ __ ]
like that what ended up happening there
were two different disputes that I think
are being conflated there was a dispute
between John Bell and Benjamin batts who
was not Kate batts as husband that was
like her brother-in-law or something
like that they didn't even they barely
knew each other Benjamin batts there was
a there was a thing where John Bell was
trying to buy a slave girl off him and
apparently John Bell gave him $100 and
then didn't get the slave right away and
then when he did get the slave
apparently Benjamin batts came back and
said no I want her back to resell her
because if she didn't I don't know if he
thought like she was more valuable than
that and he thought he got ripped off or
something like that so it was kind of an
argument about it John Bell said okay
well you can have her back for 150 at
which point Benjamin paid 120 and then
he said no that's okay and then there
was like a thing with the church and the
church said no that was that was all
cool you know what John Bell did but
apparently Benjamin batts was still
pissed off about it so he took the
matter to actual court and John Bell got
convicted of usury of you know charging
excessive interest which at the time was
kind of a big deal John Bell as a result
of his conviction for usury was
excommunicated from the church where he
had been an elder so so I think that's
where so there was actually a big is
this
documented there's court records of it
and everything and there's Church
minutes of his excommunication so there
was actually like um you know a dispute
there with someone in the batts family
but it wasn't Kate batts and it wasn't
her husband you know what I mean and it
didn't have anything to do with the land
deal now there was a dispute about a
land deal but that happened with a
different guy that was like a farmer
named Josiah fort that happened in like
eighteen sixteen or eighteen eighteen
and there was like there's court records
of that too but so I think that there
that these kind of three things became
enmeshed in people's minds where they
felt like Benjamin batts and Kate batts
were married and then there was a land
deal and it went bad and then she got
mad at John batts about her at John Bell
about it and then like cursed him and
all this other kind of [ __ ] but that's
not actually what happened like I said
there was not much relation between that
was like Benjamin batts wasn't Kay Pat's
his husband and that wasn't a land deal
it was about a slave and it was her
brother-in-law and it didn't have
anything to do with her and like I said
I think it was because she had a little
bit of a reputation around town too but
then and then there's stories too
because apparently her family had come
to Tennessee from North Carolina too I
believe because I guess like a lot of
families like went there like in a wagon
tree like at the same time there were
also rumors that John Bell and Kate
batts had been having an affair and that
he dumped her like after they got to
Tennessee actually the story went that
he killed her like that he put her in a
smokehouse and like smoked her to death
and then she haunted him but like I said
she didn't she lived much longer than he
did she died like 23 years after he did
she I believe she even outlived his wife
Lucy so obviously she couldn't come back
as it goes because she was still alive
so you know there was that whole thing
there were also some kind of stories
that that back in North Carolina that
John Bell he had had like a slave that
had fallen in love with one of his
daughters Mary and that he killed the
slave and that maybe that was why this
whole thing had started tormenting them
and [ __ ] like that but there's like all
these weird kind of like little stories
about it that don't really have much
base
in fact or there's no way of like
establishing it's far far removed from
the original report it is yeah I mean
like I said a lot of stories have come
about later and II well even at the time
there was you know rumors about what
might have caused you know this whole
thing to take place and I think there
was like a lot of rumors about the
family like I said the whole thing about
Kate batts I think that that rumor
started a long time ago like because I
believe that [ __ ] was even in Martin
Ingram's book and maybe even before that
the whole thing about Kate batts even
though like I said she didn't have
anything to do with the dispute that got
him excommunicated and even in all the
records of his excommunication and of
his conviction for usury that happened
at that time they don't mention any of
the you know that there wasn't any
mention of like oh he has like all this
like [ __ ] going on like extenuating
circumstances or anything which you
think they would have mentioned if he
was being like tormented by a demon or
whatever but they didn't mention it at
the time it wasn't the story didn't come
out like I said I believe the very very
first mention of unusual activity in the
you know at the Bell household was until
like the 1850s yeah or possibly the late
1840s if that Saturday Evening Post
article existed and even if that did
exist it basically was just saying that
something happened a long time ago that
something had one that something
happened a long time ago too they just
pretty much said it was just voices and
three implied that Betsy Bell was just
using ventriloquism
in order to get Joshua Gardner to marry
her that's what I'm gonna say there's a
chance that something did happen there
but it's it's nothing like the stories
you hear now yeah you know if something
happened there'd be more like something
along the lines of the infield or
Mammoth Mountain something like that
yeah and maybe it was remembered by some
of the locals but then other Outsiders
got involved and wanted to make a buck
buck off of it wrote books yeah and like
I don't think there's I just don't think
the Bell Witch story as commonly
understood by you know the people that
are talking about it mostly that's not
that's not what
happened yeah it because that story came
70 years later yeah I mean with all the
details that everybody knows today the
ones that they made the movies out of it
all yeah they're kind of steps too too
late yeah that happened that wasn't
published until much later yeah and like
I said as far as I know there were no
contemporaneous accounts yeah of I mean
nobody wrote down right that's the time
that it was going on so that means
there's no way for these people writing
these stories 70 years later to go back
to a source material yeah nothing there
I mean this area what are they gonna do
they might make [ __ ] up I mean they're
very very by it you know by very
generous estimate the earliest you know
possible source which may not even exist
was 29 years after the you know
manifestations supposedly and NSC 29
years and it seems to be talking about
may be mild poltergeist that's what I
wish and all of that stuff just
mentioned voices maybe a couple years
later it went on to like oh it spilled
milk it but like no violence no killing
anyone
no anything like that all of those
details emerged much in Martin Ingram's
book at seventy years later in the
1800's was a [ __ ] eternity yeah cuz
they just didn't keep proper records
back then especially in rural areas and
like I said the guy that wrote the red
book the famous red book was not alive
when elves he hadn't even been born when
all of the stuff was supposedly going on
and even if he wasn't making up the
diary even if that diary was real one
where is it where is it yeah - but even
let's even let's argue that it is real
even if it is real it was written 30
years after the stuff happened by
somebody who was 6 years old at the time
so I don't remember anything from when I
was 6 years old I remember stuff but not
not much not that write a book not
enough to write a book about where is
this where is the diary that's what I
mean now if they could find the diary
right I mean it wouldn't be great
because it wasn't written at the time
the [ __ ] was going on but it would be at
least something
you know what I mean it would have been
at least closer to the time where the
[ __ ] actually happened that's the
problem with a lot of these and I kind
of encountered this a lot when I was
writing like unseen hand and stuff and
it even happens like with some you know
less esoteric type select true crime and
everything the farther you get away from
something the more shits gonna get
changed it's like a game of telephone
you know what I mean it's like somebody
rates one wrong thing over here somebody
repeats it and before you know it it's
like everybody knows that even though
somebody just like made an error over
here maybe and then everybody just
started repeating it and in those in in
these times that we're talking about
these were this was not scientific and
historical documentation we're talking
about right we're talking about someone
who's trying to sell the book and it's
sensationalism it's all witness
testimony and storytelling yeah so all
you can say is is that you could say
that it was reported it was reported 30
years ago something happened over here
yeah that's what their that's what
they're basing all these books on 30
years ago something happened
so the Bell Witch story as the average
person knows it now is actually 70 years
removed from when it supposedly happened
yeah there's very little written records
this is all oral stuff being yes down
and boy that that could get out of hand
very quickly well I'm like I said and it
doesn't even it's not even necessarily
that people are knowingly being
deceptive even it's like they might have
like heard something from their mom or
something like that and they're just
like repeating a story that they they're
not lying or they don't you know it's
like oh my mom told me and I believe her
so they're just telling you what they
heard you know what I mean if anything
happened there long ago was some kind of
poltergeist activity and yeah people
later remembered it and then somebody
just wrote a book because people
remember that 30 years ago yeah and he's
gonna write whatever he wants to write
which there was nothing recorded yeah
and like I said you everyone was dead at
that point so you know yes they're
extended descendants were still alive
you know still are but all of the
immediate family members actually all of
the people that had lived through it
all of their children were all dead by
then one of the things that stands out
to me is that for the most part a lot of
the phenomenon seems to be coming from
somewhere in the zeitgeist yes some of
it's real old stuff from the 1600s some
of its 1800s medium-level you know like
when mediums and seances and some of it
sounds kind of like poltergeist activity
yeah so they're kind of just taking a
little bit of everything from the
paranormal field at the time of writing
yeah you know that's a lady team
Hatter's one interesting theory that I
just read an essay about it in this and
it's online like if you want to check it
out um Joe Nickell who writes for a
skeptical Inquirer he's also written
like a bunch of different books I have
one of his unlike a you know freak shows
like in the circus and stuff it's really
good but he wrote an article about his
theory that the Bell Witch story as
written by Martin Ingram was actually
not intended to be a true account he was
just taking the legend and he was
constructing a Masonic allegory around
it and he points to like several I can't
remember all of them at the time but
like like I said the articles online
just search to Joe Nickell Bell Witch
and it'll come up I think the articles
just called Bell Witch poltergeist and
he like makes a fairly convincing case
that some of the details that were put
into the story by martin ingram were
coated masonic you know kind of then
another mason would have understood it
was like it was like a masonic
allegories yeah we picked out some stuff
remember about the the jumping coffins
yeah yeah that had Masonic yeah
allegories in it so they kind of
evidently did that in the paranormal
scene back in the days when that's what
yeah and that's what he's saying that a
lot of these kind of stories were not
necessarily intended to be fiction or
nonfiction but we're like intended to be
allegorical and like someone else would
understand like another person that was
in the Masons within the Masons would
understand the symbolism and he did I
mean one particular one that I remember
he's like you know the story where they
talk about like the
[ __ ] telling these two guys hey go dig
here and you know there's a treasure or
whatever he's like they're very specific
in the size of the hole that they're
supposed to dig and like it's in the
southwest corner of this and that and
you know what I mean so he kind of makes
a convincing case that he might have
been making Masonic symbolism type hide
Masonic messages in it in this story
which like you said that was kind of a
common thing in that type of like occult
literature like paranormal type
literature I guess when spiritualism was
becoming a big thing so some of its lost
and some of the context is lost over
time yeah we're not in that same culture
and that's like something that we kind
of pointed out I think when we were
talking about like that hum like in a 40
in archaeology that show that we did a
while back where we were talking about
understand what they were doing was
trying to [ __ ] support [ __ ] Adam
and Eve and creationism there was that
was like a jaunt that was a whole genre
because a modern person doesn't see that
right you wouldn't you would you know
they're like you know they don't see
that as support of creationism because
we're not worried about that anymore
yeah but like back then that was a big
deal so like I said that's why it kind
of allotted and you know some of the
other stories we've done about like
various other urban legislate the mad
gasser of Mattoon and Spring Heeled Jack
and all that kind of stuff it seems
weird to us now like why the [ __ ] would
anybody think of that but at the time we
don't but we don't know the context we
don't live we didn't live back then it's
like they had a lot of different
concerns there were like different you
know memes kind of if you want to use
that word like happening at the time
that everyone kind of knew about but
that nowadays it wasn't preserved so you
wouldn't know about it and I think
that's kind of the case here like a lot
of the details that were added since you
know no one from back then is still
alive now and you know so much knowledge
and of that you know the context in
which the [ __ ] was written is lost I
don't think that you can really create
if you were to go back in time and pull
one of those guys back from the 1800s
and show him some of this stuff that
you'd probably get a totally different
interpretation yeah I'm sure you wait
yeah him oh he was doing it and this
another guy who worked for another
another newspaper was writing this other
stuff and they were at a they were in a
war with each other yeah right this kind
of story and everybody knew you know
like and I think like I said I know what
it go on I think that happened to what I
mean I think that happened like I said
with the story about the pterodactyl
like and that's stalactite or whatever
yeah I think that for [ __ ] real when
I first read it but what it is the more
I read about it it's like when you go
back to the original source
it was pretty clearly if you kind of
read between the lines it was pretty
clearly written as a fictional account
but in a way to make it sound real but
also in a way that everyone at the time
would have known that it was because
like I said they did that type of [ __ ]
back then I mean we say found like you
know we're talking about the Blair Witch
Project we're talking about
found-footage now that's not a new genre
it's just you know we do it with video
now but back then they did it with
manuscripts yeah but it was the same
thing Victorian infotainment yeah that's
exactly what it was so that like I said
that again that's not a new thing and
it's not a new thing to like conflate
like history with fantasy it's like
they've been doing that since time
immemorial that's where all legends and
urban legends come from I mean like I
said the Bell Witch story it's a cool
story and it's probably the most famous
I would say it's probably the most
famous American ghost story wouldn't I
mean now it is you know like I said when
I was growing up I know about it cuz my
grandparents are from there but you know
I feel like it didn't really kind of
permeate the public consciousness until
Blair Witch Project and all the
subsequent bill which movies came back
mythos ism and Jesus mythos ism yes I
mean if there was a Jesus a real Jesus
walking around preaching nothing nothing
of that survives no that survives
because there's been so so many layers
like stacked on top of it over the
millennia all been replaced in order to
combat other religions and for politics
and stuff like that every every story
about Jesus is actually a story borrowed
from another religion to counter that
religion and appropriating from other
religions which in a way makes me kind
of sad because I mean things that
happened that long ago you will never
know what the objective truth was you
will never know what really happened
even stuff that happened as recently as
you know relatively recently is the Bell
Witch incident will probably never the
truth of that either right because
there's just no way of knowing I mean
unless something comes to light that was
written at the time and even then it
could be a forgery it's like you know
there's a Mel
things that it could be so it's just
there's no way of knowing like what
really happened I think we covered it up
we probably did all right
let's shut it down so we hope you guys
enjoyed this episode like I said what do
more paranormal so we've learned do Bell
which goes yeah because I knew all about
that chick growing up it's kind of a
cool story so I hope you guys enjoyed
this breakdown of the Bell Witch legend
remember if you liked the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show it would be much
appreciated you can go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
you get to see all of them a day ahead
so that's super exciting and with that
we will shut down episode 173 we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]